[Musique]
nous allons redonner lecture des
articles du code civil des droits et de
devoirs respectifs des époux articles
212 les époux se doivent mutuellement
fidélité secours et assistance et on
veut y mettre
c'est à la mairie de limeil brévannes
que monsieur mailly à 77 ans ancien
conducteurs la ratp épouse ilham
rousseau 74 ans coiffeuse à la retraite
ici au centre hospitalier emile roux
c'est la fête la fête à l'amour l'a fait
à l'espoir comme celui ci que vous êtes
rencontre est les deux oui exactement
sur la grand art à mu des marronniers
c'est là que nous y serons prêts nos
premières aux je me rendais au pays vers
les petits à craig jamais besoin
j'ai rencontré cette lui elle avait
déposé yeux bleus une lèvre haut
elle m'a plu à votre âge de mariage est
très différent je vous dirais cette
chose on ne peut pas s'imaginer non de
mariage et mieux parce que on a un
rapprochement une tendresse qu'on n'a
pas dans la jeunesse penser la même
chose
moi je voudrais apporter à mon épouse
qui est notre pack la manière depuis
qu'elle passe nos derniers jours de
bonheur qu'est ce que vous espérez
maintenant
mais l'amour et l'eau fraîche ne
suffisent pas à présent les nouveaux
mariés ont besoin d'un logement
ce logement est devenu l'obsession
langue ouest monsieur et madame mayer
ils ne peuvent se payer le luxe de
remplir durant des années des
formulaires leur conte de fées est
impatient il n'attendra pas
[Musique]